let's see what's new on YouTube wow I
can't believe this bro there's way too
much ecchi in your highschool of the
dead review like I can't believe it I
only saw that show for the plot man do
you know kids might be watching this
like children like they're gonna see
female cleavage what were you thinking
man I'm gonna flag e worse than I a flag
I'm shine bro wow you are such a weed
buddy like your total weeaboo man wave
wave oh man it's the stroll again dude
Joey's half Japanese he lives in Japan
he speaks Japanese and how can you call
anyone a weeb with that profile pic come
on keep them 101 dude at exactly two
minutes and 35 seconds you said that
there were 13 universes in Dragon Ball
super when there are clearly 12 like
what were you thinking noob gaijin
Goomba what do you not realize that
gaijin is a Japanese word while Goomba
is an Italian word like you you're
appropriating Japanese an Italian
culture bro like how can you even do
that like that's terrible oh hey anime
fan girl 2004 guess what that video you
and your friends made about how you like
anime sucked ass like what like your
camera was moving all over the place you
guys didn't know what you were talking
about it was totally disorganized
totally a mature man like wow I can't
believe I wasted 45 minutes of my life
watching your crappy video man you do
know what this girl is only like 16
years old
and it's her first video give her a
break oh yeah I'm only 11 like yeah like
I I still watch like recess every
Saturday morning and I totally pay bleh
blades and stuff man i'm pretty sure
risa stop tearing like 10 years ago it
didn't even make beyblades anymore
you're a wee bro oh hey the anime man
listen I don't know what's with your
beard bro like you look like such a
scrub like you look so dirty and stuff
like why don't you shave that thing man
I'm just saying man bro why'd you shave
your beard like you look so girly now
like you look like eight years old like
why would you do that man what's wrong
with you just saying man man just
thought that was so my was almost
exactly same except I had to put rather
on top oh man no he didn't know he did
it man oh dude did you just advertise
your channel on I shines video shame on
you bro like I'm gonna I'm gonna flag
you right now I'm gonna flag your
comment and mark it as spam like oh man
this is gonna feel good this is gonna
feel so good ah yes oh hey lost pause
for like lost cause buddy like I'm so
sick of your stupid reaction videos like
what like who who wants to watch some
guy react to videos that other people
made you do realize just reacting to
someone else's reaction in here right
whatever whatever bro like whatever man
I bet you just like sit there in the
dark by yourself commenting on youtube
videos all day like whatever bro get a
wife man I'm not this
man we stopped all my comments no matter
what I just watching one tree hill like
what are you talking about